So President Donald Trump has come to the
realization that he probably needs fraud in
order to win reelection in November.
He needs to suppress the vote in order to
have a solid shot at defeating Joe Biden.
And his administration isn't even hiding it
anymore.
There's a new report which I encourage you
to read in Politico, explaining that Trump's
aides, Trump staffers, the people around him
know this and they're now looking at any way
they can come up with to suppress the vote,
curb, vote by mail, disenfranchize as many
people as possible when they are people that
are likely to vote for Joe Biden rather than
Donald Trump.
Now, you might remember last week I told you
we shouldn't be that confident in Joe Biden's
lead.
And that's true.
That hasn't changed.
If you look at polls that have Biden up nine
and you see that there's a margin of error
of three and a half.
That means Joe Biden might only be up by two.
Hillary won by two in 2016 in the popular
vote and still lost the Electoral College.
That analysis from last week is true.
And in particular, if anything, changes between
now and November, that helps Donald Trump
a slightly improved economy.
We'll talk about Q3 GDP numbers, which we
will get literally four days before the election.
We could see a one or two point swing away
from Biden and towards Trump.
And Trump gets reelected.
So that's all true.
But it is also clear that it's too close for
comfort.
And the report in Politico points out that
there is a complete and total commitment from
the Trump campaign to a strategy not of improving
the country, not of improving the economy,
not of dealing with coronavirus.
The strategy is essentially fraud to suppress
the vote so that the will of the people is
not accurately represented.
This is not the type of fraud, by the way,
that they claim exists.
Trump now has spent two, three months, I guess,
pushing the idea that there was in-person
voter fraud back in 2016 and in 2020 there
will be vote by mail fraud.
If more people vote by mail, remember, Trump
has not accepted the popular vote result of
the 2016 election, which had him winning the
presidency.
Trump won electorally in 2016.
He lost the popular vote by millions of votes.
He still has not accepted that.
And now he insists if we increase mail in
voting in 2020, it will be a fake, fraudulent
rigged election.
The real there will be fraud.
But the real fraud is what Trump is doing
to suppress the vote.
The real fraud is what Trump is doing to prevent
vote by mail and to kneecap the post office.
And we're already seen seeing bins of mail
overflowing and post offices across the country
as postal workers are restricted in being
able to work overtime to get the mail delivered.
If you want fraud in the sense of someone
preventing the will of the people from being
done, it's what Donald Trump and people around
him are doing and they have gone fully mask
off.
They're not even pretending otherwise.
And when you actually look at the full list
of what they're doing, it should be criminal.
Now, if we want to give Trump a consequence,
it's removing him in November.
Right.
What he's doing should be criminal.
But I mean, forget it right there.
That's not going to be the way it's handled.
You've got a massive effort in a bunch of
states to file lawsuits, to change voting
rules when it comes to vote by mail and voting
absentee.
That includes Minneapolis, Minnesota, rather,
Pennsylvania and Nevada.
Aides are trying to figure out what executive
orders can Trump sign to just unilaterally
curb mail in voting through any possible means.
They're looking at how can they stop mail
in ballots from being counted after Election
Day.
As many of you know, depending on state rules,
as long as the postmark date of the mail in
ballot is before the election or no later
than Election Day.
It would still be counted and usually mail
within states doesn't take more than a couple
of days to be delivered.
And those vote but ballots would be counted
in the couple of days after Election Day.
Trump is looking to limit that.
And Trump is also looking, according to aides.
Speaking to Politico, Trump is looking at
could he tell the Postal Service not to deliver
certain ballots that states send out?
All of this is on the table.
Now, here is the really important message.
A bunch of experts in voting have looked at
everything that they are planning.
They've looked at all of these ways in which
Donald Trump could suppress the vote.
And they've come to the conclusion that these
techniques can only do so much.
In other words, if you slow down mail delivery,
OK, you can delay it.
But if people vote early enough, few send
in your absentee ballot to three weeks before
the election.
It's going to get there before Election Day,
even if Trump slows down the post.
Well, service to some degree.
A lot of this stuff is done at the state and
local level.
So the takeaway is slowing down the mail,
finding executive orders to hamper delivery
of mail in ballot.
All of this different stuff.
It can only do so much.
And
if
we overwhelm the vote, it's going to be more
powerful than anything Trump can do from what's
been floated so far.
So, yes, at the state and local level between
now and November, we need to do everything
we can to push governors and election officials
to run the election properly, to not allow
these dirty tricks to actually take hold.
We need to do everything we can.
Yes, at the federal level.
We've got Trump's postmaster general who needs
to continually be dragged before House committees
to testify and to be put on the defensive
about what he's doing.
But he still might get away with some of this
stuff.
But in the end, the cumulative effect of all
of these techniques, all of these ideas, it
can only do a little bit of suppression if
our turnout is low.
It could hand the election to Donald Trump
if our turnout is high.
It will not make a difference if we overwhelm
the vote.
And that includes when you can safely vote
in person doing it, when you can vote by mail,
sending in your ballot two, three, four weeks
early.
Meaning if it takes off an extra five days
to be delivered, it's not going to be a problem.
These techniques cannot put Trump back
in the Oval Office.
If, if, if, if, if we vote.
And that's
the good news.
Now, we also can't ignore.
The foreign meddling.
Peace.
And
that's
what I
want
to
talk about next.